[Musique]
alors l'apiculture haut rhinoise
représente environ 2000 apiculteurs sur
ses 2000 apiculteurs nous sommes 95% de
petits producteurs roi de purée à tisser
un petit 5 % de professionnels nous
tourner aux environs de 15 mille russe
aujourd'hui la bei est en grande
souffrance pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est qu'on a créé des airs où
la belle n'a plus de quoi survivre à des
zones où il n'y a plus rien pour le pour
qu'elles avaient pu suivre
nous avons également créé des zones de
la bei à des agresseurs
sur le plan des traitements
d'aujourd'hui la bei ne peut plus vivre
dans notre environnement sans l'aide de
l'apiculteur on ne travaille beaucoup
dans le domaine des formations pour
justement former de nouveaux apiculteurs
et aussi pour les inciter à faire de
l'élevage parce qu'avoir des abeilles
est une chose mais il faut aussi savoir
élever ses abeilles et ça c'est très
important et c'est dans ce domaine là
que nous la fédération des habitudes au
lioran nous travaillons aujourd'hui nous
ont tous deux sont ici non pas pour
vendre ce n'est pas le but mais de faire
connaître au mieux que nous produisons
en alsace nous avons une ruche
pédagogique où nous expliquons un peu le
travail de l'apiculteur et le travail
pour soigner ses voeux
[Musique]
oh